HOW THAT ALL HANDLESWAY THERE BO
GOT A WEAK BACKHAND GOES
INTO THE HOCKEY HOCKEY HALL OF
ANOTHER IDENTIFICATION AGAINST
TORONTO.
IMMONDS.
AND
>> BRACKNELL WORKSN THE
POWERPLAY, PALMIERI PLAYS IT TO.
>> LAST REACH FOR THEM
HAVE TO TRY TO DO EFFECTIVELY
KERFOOT TRY TO
GET TO SECOND
PLACE AND HOME ICE.
CAMPBELL SCOOPS IT OFF THETCH GE
BOSSY PLAYED, SAME AS MATTHEWS,
65 GOALS KERFOOT.
LOOKED LIKE HE WAS GOING TO
SHOOT, STOPWERE HAVING
CAREER YEARS, HOLD
AGAIN.
>> MARNER TO RIELLY, AND RIELLY
STUMBLE IT, KEEPS IT
ALIVE.
TAVARESATE GOAL, MITCH MARNER
SOROKIN.
>> Craig: YOU KNOW, DURING TAVA,
RIELLY GTILL HAVE GIORDANO OUTH.
>> SO THE ISLANDERS COME OUT
WITH SOME URGENCY NET.
BARZAL FLIPS IT,
AND IT ENDS UP I
THAT YOU ALIVES IT.
DIDN'T GET PAST THE STEADY APPLE
HE WILLN CREATED AND
SUSTAINED BY LEAFS HERE IN THE
THIRD. 34-23 IN FAVOUR OF
TORONTO AS THEY OPEN IT IN THAT
CATE GOAL AND A EQUALIZER FOR
THE ISLANDERS.
NOWRAB THAT ONE AND THIS TIME
HOLD ON. NELSON, PAGEAU,
NYLANDER BROKE IT UP, SWINGS IT
DOWN THE